[Music]
what up
internet creatures i'm dave rubin it's
the reuben report direct message for
november 11th 2020.
there's a lot to talk about in the world
before i get to what we're doing today
i dave rubin will be getting on a plane
today
for the first time since february i have
not
left los angeles since february i'm
going to leave this crazy city in this
banana state
i'm heading to texas people i'm going to
dallas for undisclosed reasons
i've already said too much but i'll send
some pictures i'll post some things
in dallas and i'm going to be doing the
show over at the blaze studios and now
i've really said too much so keep an eye
out for that
our direct message will be live tomorrow
from blaze studios in dallas and then
i'm doing a bunch of stuff
with the guys over there i'm psyched for
that uh today we're doing three stories
uh first i referenced a video yesterday
that i wanted to pull up today this is
an interview that wolf blitzer
who is part man part wolf part
journalist
part not journalist uh wolf blitzer on
cnn he
interviewed attorney general bill
barr not built bar i sometimes promote
built bar
that sort of sounds like bill barr and
then yesterday i also referenced bob
barr who was a georgia
congressman a while back but attorney
general bill barr
william barr was on wolf blitzer's show
back in june and he was talking about
potential mail in fraud they had about
an eight minute exchange we're going to
show about two minutes of it
but if you if you watch it now compared
to everything happening in the world
right this moment it's it's pretty
mind-blowing so we're going to show that
that's
story number one story number two we're
gonna dive a little bit more
into the voter fraud situation and and
more
importantly you know i like to focus on
the media reaction to it the type of
stuff that they cover and the type of
stuff that they don't cover
uh the new york times front page of the
new york times today
there's nothing to see here people uh
yet there is some
stuff to see here people and we're gonna
talk about some of that stuff and i'm
even gonna use
videotape uh and then finally this is
the story i'm most looking forward to
because it's just
absolutely insane the cdc the center for
disease control
you know one of the many people and
organizations that
were telling us back in march we got 15
days to flatten the curve we've got new
guidelines for thanksgiving people
and uh they ain't pretty they ain't
pretty i
don't think i will be abiding by these
guidelines but you know me
i'm a rebel daddy what can i tell you uh
but before we get to all that guys i
want to talk to you
about second thoughts the board game
second thought second thoughts is this
year's favorite party game that's sure
to be the hit
in your next game night after the
election results come in which
they sort of have maybe kinda it'll be
more necessary than ever to connect with
family and friends over some
light-hearted fun
david and i always host thanksgiving
we're gonna do it this year
and we're looking forward to playing
second thoughts after some delicious
turkey and stuffing the play of the game
calls for each team to quickly create a
list of words for their opponents to
decipher leading to hilarious but
puzzlement and laughter
simply put guys it's a classic word
guessing game with a unique twist that
allows players to personalize
the content with their voluminous sense
of word smithery
or just their witty and warped
imaginations each round of second
thoughts is a hilarious high-speed
attempt to stump the other team
both team teams create a list of five
things using the letters revealed from
the color dice
be witty and wise but don't take too
long because time is not on your side
the amount of time it takes your team to
create the list is the exact
amount of time your opponents get to
guess them i gotta say this game is
really fun
after a glass or two of wine whiskey or
other assorted beverage
second thoughts guys the quick thinking
verse fast talking party game and for
the month of november the game will be
on sale at a special price
so be sure to get yours today at second
thoughtsthegame.com that's second
thoughtsthegame.com
or at your local target store and now
back to me
all right so let's talk about bill barr
not
built bar or bob barr bill barr is the
attorney general
and yesterday i mentioned that months
and months ago
he was warning us about potential fraud
with
male in ballots now that doesn't mean
fraud
occurred but over the course of the last
few months we've sort of been talking
about it right like between the pandemic
and riots and protests and everything
else we also significantly
changed the way we do voting meaning we
put much more emphasis on mail and
ballots
i can tell you guys and i'm sure many of
you that follow me on twitter
have seen this that at my old house in
la our mailbox was being broken into
constantly and i would have people on
our nest video i had video
of the people actually doing it that
doesn't prove that anyone stole
ballots or anything else but there's
just weird stuff out there
and all of these people that are
suddenly pretending that the system is
perfect
it's like they would be telling you the
exact worse uh
the exact reverse if they got what they
wanted in this case
so let's throw to this video this is
wolf blitzer again this is back in june
interviewing bill barr about
mail-in ballots and the potential for
fraud here we go
which is the bipartisan commission
chaired by jimmy carter
and james baker said back in 2009
that mail-in voting is fraught
with the risk of fraud and coercion
since then and
until this administration let me talk
yeah please
uh and since this since that time there
have been
in the newspapers in networks academic
studies
saying it is open to fraud and coercion
the only time the narrative changed is
after this administration came in
but elections that have been held with
mail have found substantial fraud and
coercion
for example we indicted someone in texas
seventeen hundred ballots collected
he made from people who could vote he
made them out
and voted for the person he wanted to
okay because that kind of thing happens
with mail inbox and everyone knows but
there are individuals
cases but as far as widespread fraud we
haven't seen that since
uh so we have we haven't had the kind of
widespread use of mail-in ballots is
being proposed
we've had absentee ballots from people
who request them from a specific address
now what we're talking about is mailing
them to everyone on the voter list when
everyone knows those voter lists are
inaccurate
people who should get them don't get
them which is what has been one of the
major
complaints in states that have tried
this in in municipal elections
and uh people who get them are not the
right people they're people who have
replaced the occup the previous occupant
and they can make them out and sometimes
multiple ballots come to the same
address
with a whole generation several
generations of occupants
do you think that's a way to run a vote
well the only thing i'm saying is that
so far we haven't seen widespread fraud
but so far we haven't tried it well and
the point is that a lot of us
there are several states that only have
mail-in voting
including a republican this is playing
with fire this is playing with fire
we're very closely divided country here
and if people have to have confidence in
the results of the election and the
legitimacy of the government
and people trying to change the rules to
this to this methodology which
as a matter of logic is very open to
fraud and coercion
is reckless and dangerous and people are
playing with fire
all right so there's a lot there people
are playing
with fire that's what he was saying back
in june now first off i want to give
credit where credit's due
considering that wolf blitzer is one of
the first part robot
part human hosts on television i think
his ability to interact with the guests
is quite good so that goes to show you
that they are
updating the software on these uh these
cable news hosts
uh but there's a couple oh i'm sorry you
know what guys i you know i said
uh that this video was from uh june it's
actually from september so that even
proves the point
even further it's even more recent uh
it's not june we were originally going
to play some audio
uh of something that bilbar said in june
we swapped it at the last second
my bad i correct on the fly there you go
uh so this took place in june this
interview not uh sorry this interview
took place in september
not in june just to be very clear uh
okay so there's a whole bunch there that
i want to reference so first
billbar says that obviously mail in
ballots for a series of reasons are
quote open to fraud and coercion meaning
that they could mail multiples
to one house that sometimes people move
and then you could still mail in the
ballot that came to you
that it sometimes even referenced that
it could happen generationally
he used an example of uh this this
person in texas
who got 1700 ballots and made out all of
them and then wolf blitzer's response
was well that's an individual case not
widespread but then bill barr said well
we don't know
how many other times this has happened
so i am mentioning all of this
not to say that the election
was automatically illegitimate or
wrought with fraud or anything else i
think there are
markers that would make us curious and
the fact that the the mainstream media
is going
out of their way to make us feel that
there's nothing to see here actually
makes me
feel more that there is something to see
here but i think it's important to show
that that
bill barr is based basically i would say
respected
across the aisle although we live in
this odd partisan time that i'm sure
they're going to tell you he's a white
supremacist soon enough
but in effect he was warning about just
this in september
he gave an example of how it can happen
and what they keep saying i mean this is
the new meme
out there they'll go oh there are
individual cases that's what wolf said
but you're seeing this throughout the
media right now
there are individual cases but it's not
widespread
well how many individual cases in how
many different places
actually lead to something being
widespread i don't know what the answer
to that is
because i don't know what counts
technically as
widespread i mean if it was widespread
throughout all throughout one
state let's say and then that state
flipped and the election came down to
that state well that seems pretty
widespread
and important now if we have minor
things in different states and i'm not
even saying that it's all the same in
all the states
the point is there's something to talk
about here and the fact that people are
afraid to talk about it or you think
you're going to be put on aoc's list
or something else it's like man if
that's where we are then this isn't
america anymore and i'm
i'm willing to take a bet on america
that this still is america and that's
how i'm going to behave
so let's explore this stuff i think i
think in effect
we have to explore this stuff and the
fact that the attorney general
was talking about it before the election
uh there was there was another line in
there that i wanted to get to
so he said that you're playing with fire
and then
he mentioned this thing about confidence
and
i think this is the important part that
right now from what i can tell
most people do not have confidence in
the system we have some people doubling
down this so
think about really what's happening here
we have had virtually half the country
and the entire media establishment and
big tech and everything basically
telling us that russian collusion and
they hacked the election
and trump is illegitimate and hillary
clinton even said
that she she should have been president
and a series of things they have never
accepted the election right and that
there was all sorts of things going on
and blah blah blah
well now because they seem to think that
biden won or trump lost
now we're not allowed to question
anything so the same people who ran with
a lie that ultimately led to
a failed impeachment are now saying no
no no there's absolutely nothing to see
here i mean
it's the highest hypocrisy that you can
possibly imagine
and for the zillionth time that in and
of itself doesn't mean that anything
is untoward it doesn't mean that there
was fraud
but the hypocrisy of oh i look at things
when when i get what i want one way and
then when i don't get what i want i look
at them another way
this is a big problem obviously this
story ain't going anywhere we'll we'll
continue
talking about it because uh
unfortunately the media is just dropping
the ball that's going to be our next
story
but before we do that folks i want to
show you
my new basketball you know how i got
this basketball and by the way
i am shooting at a very high percentage
these days i'm knocking down about 65
of open threes these days my team can
can confirm it you know how i got this
ball
i got this ball because i used my glint
pay
card this is a mock-up so don't zoom in
and try to steal something from me it's
just a mock-up it ain't a real card but
the card does
feel like this and it's a nice feeling
hefty card you're gonna dig it
uh what is glenn pay well at glint they
believe that gold is one of the possible
solutions to restoring trust in the
system
through sound money customers shouldn't
have a choice glint provides you
i'm sorry customers should have a choice
that shouldn't have a choice they should
have a choice people that's what it's
all about
glenn provides you the ability to own
and transact in real gold as though you
were saving and transacting in dollars
euros or yen instantly unlike cash gold
actually holds its purchasing power over
time
glenn allows me to buy sell save and
spend
in real gold or us dollars using my new
glint mastercard and their free glint
app that's exactly what i did when i
picked up this ball on amazon
two days ago glenn is super safe simple
and reliable
it's free to sign up so go to
glintpay.com ruben for more information
and to start purchasing gold today
that's glintpay.com
reuben to get your gold today and now
back to me
all right uh okay so let's talk a little
bit
about the media situation related to all
of this so first off
before i even dive into it i want to
show you the front page
of the new york times today let's throw
to the front of the new york times
this is their headline which says
election officials
nationwide find no fraud
all right i mean i guess that's kind of
true
election officials now these are the
same people who would be in charge of
things so if there was some fraud they
wouldn't want you to know because then
it would make
them look pretty pretty bad but you know
it's a big
title up there and it's very you know
this is what's happened and if you even
question what's happened well you're a
bad guy
we're going to throw you on the list now
i want to mention two other new york
times stories that have happened in the
last two years just to show you that
perhaps
just because something is in the new
york times and on the front page that
doesn't necessarily mean it's true
now you may remember about two years ago
when the new york times did
a front page story about how
youtubers were leading people to the
alt-right
and you know who they included in that
story well there was a big picture of my
face they actually held my face to the
third page but they had a montage of
many other people
and they talked about me and they talked
about that scary orthodox jew ben
shapiro
and that really scary uh psychologist
that sounds like hermit the frog jordan
peterson they talked about youtuber phil
defranco they talked about libertarian
economist
milton friedman and many others how we
were leading
people to the alt-right even though
literally everything i have done on this
show
for five plus years now has been against
identity politics and against
those type of authoritarian collectivist
ideas
um so that is that was the cover of the
new york times the best part of it was
they
they take there's the author of the new
york times story is a
guy by the name of kevin ruse r-o-o-s-e
although if he would just change his
name to kevin roose i think then he
would be
in a much better situation at least much
more honest but in effect he tracked
a kid who was watching videos on youtube
and he sort of was a centrist at first
and then he started watching
some jordan peterson videos some reuben
reports some other things
and then uh then he started watching
some stuff that was a little further
right but then guess what you're not
going to believe this guys
he found lefty youtube and he was saved
and he became
a big progressive so the very thesis of
the article
which was that youtube leads people to
the alt-right
was debunked by the very kid that they
based the article on
i mentioned this not to make it about me
i mentioned this because this was a
front page of the new york times article
that was filled
with lies and everything else they had
to change some of the
the text around it when people started
fighting back but it was front page of
the new york times and if that one's not
good enough for you
i'll mention uh our friend jordan
peterson again real quick because they
ran
a front page story on the new york times
about how jordan peterson
was pushing women to enforced monogamy
which sounds very scary he's forcing
women against their will
to get married it sounds like handmaid's
tale i was on tour with jordan when that
article came out i was actually in the
green room when the when the author
was interviewing jordan about that and
by enforced monogamy you can google the
phrase enforcement on me in effect
means marriage meaning that enforce
monogamy like we're gonna have some laws
around marriage
because marriage is generally good it's
one of the building blocks of society to
get us
from generation to generation to
generation he never once implied that
we'd be
forcing women to do it but it was very
it was a scary phrase and it was in
there and it actually almost derailed
the whole tour because
of the media frenzy after it i mentioned
these two stories and there's a million
more i mean
how many times was russia collusion
and ukraine and data mining and all of
these scary things
front page of the new york times
articles
they work many many many many many times
so just because the new york times is
saying something doesn't mean it's true
and i would argue at this point i mean
i've almost shifted to the place where
if the new york times tells me something
especially in a headline i pretty much
think that the reverse is true and often
one of the things that they do and i
i write about this and don't put in this
book is what they'll do is they'll give
you a headline that says one thing and
it's not till paragraph 13 where they
know nobody's gonna get to
very few people get that far in the
article well you'll realize that the
the headline actually doesn't even match
the article at all um
so it's it's propaganda now
i am not saying that election officials
nationwide find no fraud i'm not saying
that that in and of itself
is propaganda like that may be a
statement that is true elect the
election officials who are in charge of
the stuff have found no fraud
well that doesn't mean no fraud occurred
that's what the issue would be
is that you would want to talk about the
i think there's something like 11 000
affidavits have been signed by people
that are claiming that there was fraud
or negligence or something like can we
can we talk about that are we allowed to
talk about that or are agents going to
show up to our houses and throw us in
sacks
i don't know um so it's just sort of
nonsense
but to show it sort of nonsense i want
to throw to the video
we just pulled this up i think it's from
this morning it's either from this
morning or yesterday afternoon
this is cnbc and it's video of the
georgia governor
who has just announced a statewide
recount
at 1 pm today i will make the official
designation of which race will be the
subject of the rla
at that time i'll designate that the roa
will be the presidential race with the
margin being so close
it will require a full by-hand recount
in each county this will help build
confidence
it will be an audit a recount and a
re-canvas
all at once it will be a heavy lift
but we will work with the counties to
get this done in time
for our state certification
okay so that's not in direct
conflict with that headline but it shows
you there's more going on here
georgia is now going to do a hand
recount
and audit so and as he said
as he said so that we can feel good
about it right
so that we can have confidence in the
system which by the way is exactly
what bill barr from earlier was talking
about you want people to have confidence
in the system
especially when we're so partisan so
when new york times blares a headline
like that the implication is nothing
happened we shouldn't have to look at
anything and anyone who tells you
otherwise is bananas
but it was so close right now in georgia
that it triggered the recount and that
is good and again that is why
i will keep saying until this thing is
over you look at everything
you look at everything that's what a a
free democratic society does
if we were in an unfree society and
perhaps we're there already but if we
were in an unfree society
what would the powers that be do well
they would force propaganda down your
throat that
the result is the result and you can't
ask anything about it
and they wouldn't want people to be
looking at actually what happened they
wouldn't want hand recounts and audits
and everything else
so i think what's happening in georgia
is very good and by the way
if it turns out that biden wins georgia
after they've done everything then so be
it i mean that that's what democracy's
about i'm not sitting here saying i have
to win
or burn it down that's the way a certain
other set of people operate but it's not
the way i operate
so anyway the point is that we've got
georgia already saying the recount
there's there's lawsuits
in pennsylvania there's stuff going on
in arizona which keeps getting tighter
and tighter and tighter
which i think then within a certain
amount of votes can trigger an automatic
recount the point is
that there's stuff going on and you're
not paranoid or crazy
or evil if you talk about it so let's
just leave that there
and then i want to focus for the
remainder on this the cdc
guideline for thanksgiving story the
center for disease control
who like many other organizations uh
has been telling us what to do about
coronavirus and apparently what they're
telling us isn't working because it
keeps getting worse i suppose
and more cases are coming and two days
ago pfizer announced a 90
vaccine and then you know we're told
today is is the worst day that we've
ever had
it also seems odd to me that as the
election stuff about fraud gains more
momentum then suddenly we see the covid
stuff get
ramped back up i mean these are all
realistic things to talk about and i
don't think these things
are unconnected but the cdc the center
for disease control
they have updated their thanksgiving
guidelines let's let's pull them up
we've got a nice
bulleted list and i'm going to go
through all of them
bullet number one have conversations
with guests ahead of time
to set expectations for celebrating
together
jesus if celebrating indoors make sure
to open windows yeah enjoy that while
you're in the northeast that'll be fun
encourage guests to bring their own food
drinks plates cups and utensils
why not just charge the money at the
same time avoid
potluck style gatherings no double
dipping people
very important very important wear a
mask at all times when not eating or
drinking
and keep six feet apart that's gonna be
a hell of a thanksgiving table keeping
six feet apart from everybody
limit people going in and out of areas
where food is being prepared or
handled have one person who is wearing a
mask
serve all the food i mean really like ma
you know fill up my coke and get me more
potatoes
use single single use options or
identify
one person to serve shareable items like
salad dressings
food containers plates and utensils and
condiments
okay i want to be very clear about this
i'm not going to do any of this stuff
i'm not sure what we're doing for
thanksgiving this thanksgiving is
normally the the one holiday
that david and i host and we have about
10 12 family members we've been doing
this for years it's a tradition that
we've started i love thanksgiving
i love that thanksgiving it's not a
religious holiday
it's a it's a holiday about america
being thankful for what we have it's
it's a time
to just actually sort of embrace each
other and we go around the table and we
talk about what we're thankful for and
it's not you know the seasons are
changing and all that stuff so i
absolutely love
thanksgiving and the idea that the
government
is now going to tell us who can serve
the food
in our house and how close we have to
sit
with each other and that we have to keep
the windows open and the series of
ridiculous things
that is not to diminish what is
happening with kovid
but i call me crazy guys i know i'm a
radical
freedom person a real extremist over
here
i believe that you can figure out what
to do in your house related to how
you're going to celebrate holidays
and these people are absolutely
ridiculous and they want to control you
you cannot control me and i'm talking to
you cdc and i'm talking to you gavin
newsom
governor of california and i'm talking
to you eric garcetti mayor
of los angeles i'm going to have people
here and we're going to eat freely and
we're going to talk
we might sing and i'm not going to force
one person
to serve everybody and we might have
shared dishes
we might put i don't know i'm not really
sure but we i might do it out of spite
normally we would serve the plates you
know what i mean we would make the plate
for everybody
i think this year the stuffing is going
to be over here the cranberry sauce is
going to be over here the potatoes are
going to be over here the turkey's going
to be over here
everyone's going to touch the spoon okay
everyone's going to touch the spoon
it's just that's how we're doing it you
cannot control us you lunatics
have a nice day everybody i'm off to
dallas the direct message will be live
same time as always from dallas i'm
doing stuff some stuff with glenn beck
and some of the rest of the blaze team
we've got some interesting meetings
which hopefully i'll have some updates
on soon
a lot of good things happening don't go
crazy
have a good day and stay six feet away
from everybody and don't touch anybody
and everything else okay you got it okay
good
you